It all must make sense.
There has to be a reason.
Things don’t just happen.
When the finale of season two ends,
you’re left with this girl who has
kind of bested this
scary, mythic figure.
Vanity is a sin, Aunt Josephine.
And she’s sitting there on
the bed and says, you know,
I know what’s gonna happen.
I know they’re coming for us.
We pick up three months later
and Leanne is in the middle of
absolute paranoia.
I told you that we
can’t trust strangers.
She’s anticipating an attack
that hasn’t happened yet.
You ready for food, buddy?
Num num time.
On the surface you really get a
sense that the family’s doing well.
I thought you’d wanna see this.
Oh look!
I think the family has been
lulled into thinking, we made it.
I think that everything’s happening
the way that it’s supposed to.
Don't worry.
And Dorothy’s very grateful
that she has her child back.
She’s very sympathetic to Leanne
as a teenage member of a cult.
But can you leave the church?
Can you leave this cult?
I just want to understand what
you believe. That’s all.
When Leanne starts exhibiting darker
tendencies and destructive choices…
Believe me, I am frightened
about what she might do next.
Dorothy has a realization
that she’s dealing with
someone really, really unstable.
Boo.
Each character in the family
has their own point of view
about what’s happening.
Sean believes that this is a miracle,
and Leanne is the instrument of that.
I still can’t believe we’re here,
on the other side of it.
Julian is a person that struggles
with addiction in many forms,
and in this season his
addiction is Leanne.
Leanne continually starts
to surprise herself,
and her realization of
how powerful she is
grows to a scary
and very dark place.
God won’t fix you.
There’s a defiant part of
her that’s going to emerge,
and it will get kind of scary
when she’s pushed too far.
I’m doing this for you.
The fans of Servant will find
that we found our stride.
The story kind of
keeps unfolding and
you’re gonna learn more
and more about the mystery,
the things you’ve been
waiting to hear about.
And there’s so many
shocks and surprises,
there’s life and death
in every single episode.
Season three should leave
your jaw hanging open.